have you ever felt a competitiveness
from other actors auditions and if so
how do you handle I suppose you walk
into a room and there's like 10 of you
they're rude how do you keep that game
face on so that you don't let them I
mean it's just human nature you probably
feel you know I think it's kind of silly
for actors would be to be competitive
with each other man everyone's nervous
in that situation then the audition room
has a unique kind of attention to it
anyways but you know you're not
competing against each other you know
you're kind of competing against
yourself and so I think when people do
get competitive they try to psych the
other person out you know and I think
that's just kind of dirty but from my
experience I don't think guys I don't
like men do it very often but I've heard
that females and in the audition room
King can kind of get kind of nasty some
of them I think they feel a bit more
competitive and then dudes don't even
yeah I have an experienced too much
every once in a while I've seen somebody
in addition doing something so odd and
kind of obnoxious that I thought to
myself maybe that guy's trying to psych
everybody else how to distract me or do
something like that but know typically I
agree with you that it's more
everybody's kind of in their own
universe and they're nervous for the
wrong reasons and they're you're more
trying to do your own thing as best as
you can possibly do it and there's
enough ways that people are going to
self-destruct on their own they didn't
help from anybody else in audition
auditions are incredibly stressful
difficult situations I feel like most
people are worried enough about their
own thing or at least concentrated
enough on their own thing to not be
thinking about how to mess up the guy
next to you it's just sort of I guess
the my experience but maybe i don't know
maybe we you and I would like if it was
more
competitive if they're like all right
we're gonna bring you guys in or now you
do it all right how you do it all right
in a patter tops off and fight when you
dump that will go in the audition room
oh I like to come out of the other
shroom be like all right great no I'll
have my agent read the contracts then
all right I can't wait I see you go like
that it does happen feel like everybody
hey good luck get some psych out that
goes on with like the guy walks out of
the room everyone watching what he's
doing no there's a guy who comes up with
his side's and immediately frozen yeah
goes into the trash before storming out
you're like okay well that maybe didn't
go so well and there's a guy that comes
out and he's just so probably say he's
like I guess huh everybody Great Britain
guys break a leg Allah may break a leg
you're like oh us all douche uh but
you know who are you know you are break
a leg guys stop saying it it's not
saying it that's it so what's your
process when you do these after you here
great work great job thank you we have
information dude psyched we get
instantly I tweet going to gym had
rocked that audition just cried internal
yeah I don't just degraded myself I have
definitely been that guy that walks out
and it is like ripped the pages oh yeah
on my way out kiss your work and and I
put that job sometimes I have oh yeah I
know you just you just don't know it's
so awful sometimes as an actor you know
walking into a room it's like having a
job interview that's what i equated to i
think everyone most people can
understand what a job interviews like
but it's one of those job interviews
where they say oh my god you're perfect
for this job you have the wrong hair
color so you can't be the president of
United States kind of thing and it's
it's kind of depressing in that way but
it I think you train yourself as an
actor too once you walk out that door
you forget about it he totally I've been
called and said well good
man could i bet i've been going really i
could be you an audition you got that
job like what job really it's for this
movie and like I remember what that was
like it's the memory audition for last
week and I have to like can I go through
my notes like oh oh yeah I know I
remember that could have trained myself
to just not care cuz you need to do is
just eat yeah yeah I'm I haven't i've
got actually you should maybe do a class
but I could take it so does not care cuz
I still I'm very tortured by the whole i
auditioning for me is in horribly
painful difficult thing i always say to
myself and other people too and now
anyone who'll listen that if and when i
get to a point where I'm you know it
creatively in control of a project in
terms of casting and hiring people but i
just want to revolutionize the audition
process because i think it's a totally
it's not a very constructive it's not
very process and you're not really
finding the best people for the work
you're kind of just finding good
auditioners which isn't really what
again looks like yes yeah so i just
liked it i think the whole thing needs
to change i don't i think it's gotten to
a really weird place I think people are
also lazy with on the other side of the
camera they're lazy with watching
someone's real with watching someone's
previous work you know I I wouldn't hire
somebody you know I wouldn't even ask
someone to come in and take an interview
unless I'd rather resume you know
and kind of lean on red you know if I
was read some of the the what they've
done you know I think it's kind of a
lazy thing and then people just want to
hear their own material coming out of
that person's mouth and I I think that
you know there's there's room for that
but I always equated it's like have
auditioning is kind of like having a
math teacher give an English test you
know they're both teachers but it's a
whole different subject you know I'm
waiting I mean I'm waiting to find out
if one day I'm somebody who has a day to
remember thank you let's go let's up
it's good that's not distracting at all
actually this is nice there are a lot of
Simon's around here yeah but I I'm
waiting to find out like one day if I'm
in that position where I'm directing or
producing something and if and when I'm
waiting to find out that maybe there's a
reason why the casting process is to me
what seems very backward and weird but
there might be a reason I mean I might
be that guy sitting there thinking like
I just don't have time to do this I
can't read everybody's resume i can't
watch your rio i'm trying to do things
and just you know and and and I don't
care where the best actor is I'm just
waiting for someone to come in the room
and not melt down and you're gonna have
the role I just need to get this movie
made you know and I everybody I guess is
stressed out in their own way up to me
right now from somebody who strictly has
seen the audition process from the point
of the auditioner right not the audition
am I Division II on my addition error on
the addition email well the addition is
the person who's auditioning me right
and I auditioning so I am the audition
he doesn't matter ah from the point of
view the actor who's going in on
auditioning um we'll just cut that out
starting now
and that's what I think uh yeah it's it
seems we have to make I don't like I
don't like to process this was an
audition right now oh good do I get the
rope tonight no I didn't think it no do
they invent some sides that can rip up
an eternal trash for you these words
sighs oh and said everywhere well oh boy
oh boy
you